the latest Suicide Squad trailer came
out on Tuesday night showing us quite a
bit more of the upcoming film it's
divided opinion a bit whether that's
over it's dark look it's dialogue or the
fact that the trailer was set to Queen
but we're withholding judgment until we
see it in a few months time I'm Kate and
this is your gamespot news update Warner
Bros pictures has released a new trailer
for the upcoming Suicide Squad film set
the song Bohemian Rhapsody by Queen most
notably unlike the previous trailer that
debuted at Comic Con this one shows more
of Joker as portrayed by actor jared
leto in action the film is due to come
out on August fifth 2016 Suicide Squad
tells the story of a group of death row
super villains who are employed covertly
by the US government to perform
dangerous missions in return for reduced
prison sentences the movie also stars
Will Smith as dead shot and Margot
Robbie as Harley Quinn will smith
recently opened up about the unusual
experience of working with Jared Leto
I've never actually met Jared Leto said
Smith we worked together for six months
and we've never exchanged a word outside
of action and cut he was all in on the
Joker let me know what you thought of
the film in the comments or come and
find me on Twitter I'm at how not to
draw thanks for watching and for all
your gaming and entertainment news p big
game spot